[THEME MUSIC]
TIMOTHY JORDON: Hello,
and welcome to I/O live.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm standing here
with Jeff Dean, the
head of AI at Google.
JEFF DEAN: Hi, Tim.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDON: Hi, Jeff.
All right, let's start with
a background of Google's work
in AI.
JEFF DEAN: So we've been
using machine learning
and AI for the last 20 years
in some of our products.
But in the last
five or six years,
we've really sort
of dramatically
accelerated our use of
machine learning and AI
into more and more
of our products.
We've really used it to make
our products more intelligent,
to make them sort
of more accessible,
to really improve the
product, and build products
that we couldn't build
in any other way.
TIMOTHY JORDON: What's
new with the technology
that we're making available,
say the last year, and at I/O?
JEFF DEAN: In the last
year, for example,
we've made really great
strides in improving
TensorFlow, our open source
machine learning system.
One of the things I'm
really excited about
is the TensorFlow.js
release, which essentially
allows TensorFlow programs
to be run in the browser,
just as normal web pages,
with sort of machine
learning embedded code in them.
And it's really easy
for people to create
really interesting new
machine learning applications.
And then people to run them,
by just loading up a web page.
It's pretty fantastic.
TIMOTHY JORDON: And TPUs?
JEFF DEAN: So we released--
announced the third version
of our TPU processor line,
custom machine learning
accelerators.
The TPU V3 is really,
really exciting.
It's quite hot,
so it actually is
our first liquid
cooled processor
that's in our data center.
And the pods are actually
larger scale than the TPU pods
that we announced
last year, so they're
eight times as powerful.
More than 100
petaflops of compute,
which is just an unbelievable
amount of compute.
And the really exciting
thing is that allows
us to make sort of more accurate
models, machine learning
models that can train
on more data, that
can train more powerful
and more accurate models.
And then we can use that
to improve our products.
TIMOTHY JORDON: I think
one of the things that
makes me most excited
about the technology
that we're making available
is that whole spectrum, all
the way from TensorFlow JS,
which is a very accessible way
to get into machine learning,
and auto ML, all the way up
to TPUs.
So our advanced
users have all that
compute to do cool stuff with.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah, I
mean, I think there's
going to be a lot of
different levels of expertise
and experience in
using machine learning,
and we to make all
of them able to use
machine learning to improve
their products in life.
TIMOTHY JORDON: All
right so, let's talk
about what people are doing
with machine learning,
'cause we're getting there.
What are some things
that people are
doing in the world of
machine learning that you're
the most excited about?
JEFF DEAN: There's like lots
of different applications.
One that I'm really
passionate about
is the use of machine learning
to improve health care.
I think there's a real
opportunity there,
for both kind of medical
imaging related problems,
we've been doing a lot of
work on diabetic retinopathy
and other kinds of
medical imaging problems.
But also in how
patients' lives are
affected, how doctors are
able to care for patients,
with making better decisions,
a lot of advances there.
It's going to be great.
TIMOTHY JORDON: OK.
So there's these big
problems that we're
tackling with machine learning.
What about everyday problems?
Is there something that
you encounter everyday
that you would love
somebody to apply to?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah, I
think as you start
to have a machine learning lens,
as you walk around the world,
you can see things
that could be better.
For example, when I pull up
to a stoplight and it's red,
and there's no cars coming
the other direction,
that's just silly, right?
We should have
computer vision based
stoplights that
just allow people
to go when it's safe to go.
And that would be like
a simple improvement
in the world, that would
improve lots of people's lives.
TIMOTHY JORDON:
Thanks for joining me.
JEFF DEAN: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDON: And thank
you for watching I/O live.
To learn more about what
Google is doing in AI and ML,
head on over to google.ai.
And to catch more
videos like this,
head on over to g.co/io/guide.
[THEME MUSIC]